insolite à présent on va parler d'une
radio 100% dédié aux reptiles bonsoir et
10 najder bonsoir à frédéric blervaque
vous avais fonde et tous les deux une
radio sur internet 100% dédié aux
reptiles passion des reptiles points
comme c'est une drôle d'idée pourquoi
avoir fait ça pourquoi pour la bonne et
simple raison c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ad
on a des gens qui se posent beaucoup
d'un beaucoup de questions et beaucoup
d'interrogations par rapport aux
reptiles et le but de le but delà de la
radio est aussi pour changer pour
changer l'image que le terrariophile à
vis à vis de la terrariophilie tous fait
depuis chez vous oui à chevreuse oui
vous émettez chez vous vous avez acheté
du matériel comment on monte une radio
comme ça sur l'homme c'est facile c'est
facile non c'est extrêmement difficile
donc effectivement il ya énormément de
travail qui est fait derrière notamment
de recherche par rapport par rapport aux
différents médias
comment faire une programmation aussi ce
qui est important se renseigner et
regarder quelle personne on peut on peut
interviewé pour intéresser aussi
l'audimat et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de travail de recherche 100%
reptiles tous les programmes sont
consacrés aux reptiles
on parle de quoi cette radio 116,3 de
radio alors d'abord c'est une radio tout
ce qu'il ya de plus classique donc bien
évidemment il y à de la musique c'est
assez hétéroclite d'ailleurs à ce propos
au niveau des genres on essaye de sortir
des fameux cliché rock'n'roll
qui vont arriver avec sa revanche c'est
ça donc on a on a vraiment de tout ça va
du jazz en passant effectivement par le
rock mais des choses un peu plus
standard et puis on a des plages
horaires qui sont dédiés à des petites
annonces de particuliers à des annonces
de professionnels ont fait aussi la
promotion de beaucoup de nos partenaires
est en marche de ça il ya d'autres
plages qui sont dédiés à des fiches de
maintien par exemple vous avez à des
interviews à des reportages animaliers
c'est assez rare ce type de radio en
france dédié comme ça c'est la première
c'est la phase où nice est plus fréquent
aux etats unis c'est plus fréquent
effectivement ça fait déjà beaucoup
d'émules aux états unis donc on s'est
dit aux états unis ça existe en français
n'existent pas les idées les plus
simples sont les fous des fois les plus
compliquées à trouver
donc on a dit voilà on va se lancer là
vous faites ça en tant que passionné
vous imaginez en vivre également ses
objectifs bien évidemment l'objectif à
moyen ou long terme
mais pour l'instant la radio à trois
mois donc on a besoin encore du support
de nos amis les professionnels
d'ailleurs on va profiter de ce petit
passage télé pour pour faire un appel si
certains professionnels veulent faire du
sponsoring
bien évidemment on est ouvert à toute
proposition pour parler donc des
reptiles sur cette radio passion des
reptiles points comme le site internet
cette affiche et vous vous adressez à
qui justement ce sont des passionnés
comme vous là où il effectivement c'est
alors il faut savoir que au niveau des
hauts niveaux des reptiles chaque année
vous avez dit faire ce bourse bourse aux
reptiles qui sont qui sont mises en
place
justement pour vendre vendre et montrer
des nouvelles espèces aux particuliers
aux professionnels
vous interviendrez petit chez vous par
exemple
petite vingtaine de serpents oui juste
d'un certain oui pas mal vingtaine de
certains savent bien la maison
ça se passe très très bien superbe
entente avec les serpents et on a une
petite fille de 16 mois aussi qui a une
superbe entente avec des serpents aussi
nous parlons donc de cette nouvelle
radio nous sommes allés demander aux
gens s'ils avaient peur comme moi des
reptiles je vous remercie pas être venu
en plateau avec son serpent d'ailleurs
on va les écouter quelques témoignages
sa non pas si c'est grand bain j'ai pas
peur parce qu'il a dit qu'il nous offre
ça dépend un quart et il ya beaucoup
l'arrêter le dans le monde donc toute
une variété certains reptiles
sont particulièrement dangereux donc je
m'approchais pas oui je me méfierais non
moi j'ai pas peur mais j'aime pas ça
dépend des cas là
moi général non non non pas spécialement
non pas particulièrement dans les
déserts norme ça va bien ce que j'avais
aux antilles il ya eu des lézards donc
tous à l'effrayer pas trop si vous voyez
une retraite ville
après je pense que vous allez avoir peur
j'avoue il n'y a que moi qui ai peur on
parle de ces nouveaux animaux de
compagnie aussi parce qu'il ya un
engouement autour de ça les nouveaux
animaux de compagnie c'est aussi
l'objectif c'est d'accompagner les gens
qui voudraient avoir des les serpents
chez eux par exemple si avec votre radio
pour pas qu'ils fassent n'importe quoi
qui ait pas d'abus
bien entendu quand on adopte un reptile
il faut savoir que comme tout animal il
a une durée de vie et il faut la prendre
en considération un certain de nos
serpents ont une durée de vie de 20 ans
donc quand on signe c'est pour longtemps
comme pour n'importe quel autre animal
il faut bien entendu prendre les devants
et avoir le matériel en conséquence
avant d'adopter l'animal donc on invite
sur cette radio et on donne les conseils
pour que tout le matériel soit qui en
amont de l'animal pour qu'il se sente
bien et que le maintien se passe dans
les meilleures conditions possibles et
de tous à vous en parler sur votre radio
actuellement au niveau de l'audimat ça
se passe comment justement quels sont
les retours vous pouvez avoir alors au
niveau des retours c'est
on a un petit peu tout forcément on a de
la personne jalouse à la personne qui
nous dit oui effectivement les y foncez
vous avez raison aujourd'hui vous êtes
les seuls à y avoir pensé c'est une
excellente idée et on met tout de notre
côté aussi pour avoir de l'audimat et
permettre aux auditeurs de venir écouter
en gagnant notamment des places pour qui
lit avec des partenariats qui sont mis
en place avec la ferme aux crocodiles et
la planète des crocodiles qui se trouve
à poitiers et peerally et pierrelatte
pour la ferme aux crocodiles
très rapidement le prochain rendez vous
pour votre radio demain soir 21h 23h
dans l'émission on ne vous cachera rien
avec comme invités le vétérinaire bien
enceinte numéro de duettistes le comme
invité le
vétérinaire réputé dans les nac
schillinger lionel et damien morel qui
nous présentera le taurus qui est le
premier antiparasitaires vivent donc une
solution parfaitement écologique et
naturel passion des reptiles points
comme pour écouter tout ça merci à tous
les deux d'être venu sur le plateau les
informations concernant le skipper
versaillais tanguy de lamotte engagé
lors du vendée globe sur initiative
coeur que nous avons suivie depuis le
début de la compétition les dernières
heures ont été difficiles pour lui son
navire a connu une avarie technique
il s'est couché à deux reprises en
raison d'un problème apparemment de
pilotage automatique et finalement les
réparations se sont bien déroulées il a
twitté en fin de journée ses
remerciements à son public qui le suit
et fait part de sa confiance pour la
suite du vendée globe petit rappel son
navire est le plus ancien en compétition
une date de 1998 et pour l'instant il
tient bon prochain rendez vous avec l
actu à 20h30 à 22h sur tv fils l'actuel
toute image de la rédaction et puis
l'édition du week-end dès demain 18h
avec catherine mulato je vous retrouve
lundi en direct avec de nouveaux invités
bonne soirée